as fashion designers our decisions have
the power to change our culture we
choose who's casting our runway shows
and campaigns ultimately who is
celebrated and considered beautiful and
who's not having this platform is a
responsibility one that can be utilized
to exclude people or to empower others
growing up
I was obsessed with fashion I pour it
over all different types of fashion
magazine and my local Barnes & Noble to
be fashionable was to be tall skinny
with long shiny hair that's what I saw
is the ideal and it was reinforced
everywhere I looked and to be honest it
still is I wanted to be like the models
so I stopped eating it was a dark time
in my life my eating disorder consumed
me all I could think about was counting
every single calorie and waking up early
before school every day so I could run a
few miles it took me years to finally
release the grip that the eating
disorder had over my life but when it
did it freed up so much brain space to
think about what I was truly passionate
about for so long the fashion industry
has worked hard to center ideal of
beauty that celebrates thin young white
cisgender able-bodied models as the
ideal is impossible not to be bombarded
with images of models that have been
photoshopped to where there's not a
single poor fat roll or stretch mark in
sight you don't need to look hard to
find examples this definition of beauty
is damaging dangerous and destructive
and we need to explode it immediately
I'm glad you agree one of the worst
things I've realized over the years is
that my experience with disordered
eating is not an anomaly in fact it's
par for the course I think there's a
study that says 91 percent of women and
likely those of all gender identities
aren't happy with the way they look it's
unforgivable that we live in a society
where it's normal or expected for
teenagers to grow up hating themselves
we've been fighting for fat acceptance
and women's body autonomy since the 60s
and there has been headway we have
plus-size models like Ashley Graham and
musicians with body-positive messages
like Liz Oh breaking into the mainstream
thank god there's brands like area that
have released campaigns without any
Photoshop retouching but we're still
inundated with unrealistic expectations
I love this quote by Liz o who said body
positivity only exists because body
negativity is the norm so how do we
change the stigma around looking
different or not fitting into this
narrow definition of beauty
I believe it's by celebrating beauty in
all different forms bold and
unapologetically but many fashion
designers continue to reinforce this
narrow definition of beauty from the way
they're taught in school and into the
real world they drape on mannequins that
are only size 4 or sketch on bodies that
are super stretched out not anatomically
proportion different sized bodies aren't
taken into account during the design
process they're not thought of so who
are these designers designing for but
the conversation around exclusivity and
fashion doesn't begin and end with size
it's about seeing people of all
different gender expressions different
ability levels different ages different
races and ethnicities celebrated for
their own unique beauty in my own work
as a fashion designer I started a brand
called chroma and we're committed to
empowering women fans and non-binary
chroma babes of all shapes and sizes
through perfectly fit garments for every
body
swimwear has become a huge focus for me
because of the power that this single
garment
can have over the way people feel about
themselves we wanted to take our focus
on celebrating all body types - a
garment that's fraught with insecurities
on our runways you see curves cellulite
and scars worn proudly we're a runway
show yes but also a celebration
I didn't start designing ten years ago
with a mission to change the entire
industry but the models we cast at the
time who just happened to be my friends
who I begged to be in my shows were so
radical to some people and unfortunately
still is different or strange to some
that it became a huge part of what we're
known for
however inclusivity means nothing if
it's only surface level behind the
scenes from the photographer to the
casting director to the interns who's
making the decisions behind the scenes
is just as important it's imperative to
include diverse decision-makers in the
process and it's always better to
collaborate with different communities
rather than trying to speak for them and
this is an important piece of the puzzle
that many young designers may not think
about when they're first starting their
careers but hiring a plus-sized or
transgender photographer or a woman of
color as your casting director or black
makeup artist hey Fatima Thomas who
intimately understands how important it
is to be able to work with all skin
tones it's essential to creating a
holistically inclusive output like this
one as fashion designers that do a lot
of swim we wanted to rewrite the rules
around having a bikini body so he has a
team of babe guards to enforce
guidelines around inclusion and
acceptance at the pool instead of no
diving and no running how about
celebrate cellulite body policing
prohibited and intolerance not tolerated
and this was enforced by babe guards
mama Cox Denise fado Gina Rosero Erika
Hart and MA all activists in their own
right I've always felt it was important
to show a range of different bodies in
our runway shows and campaigns but it
actually wasn't until recently that we
were able to expand our size range in a
major way we first launched our curve
collect
five years ago we were so excited but
when it launched it fell flat nobody was
interested
none of our department stores stalked
above a size large and if they did it
was somewhere else in the building
entirely in fact one time my sales team
said you know so cool you have trans
models and curved models on the runway I
love what you're doing but when the
buyers come in to see the collection for
market they want to be sold a dream they
want to see something that they aspire
to be implying that our models weren't
that but I've realized it's so much more
important to open up this dream to more
people
I want the consumer to know that it's
not your body that needs to change it's
the clothes there needs to be more
fashion options at all sizes and in all
retailers so finally in 2018 Nordstrom
actually plays to order up to 3x and
this was a huge game-changer for us to
have a major retailer invest in adding
these units so we could go to the
factory and really go now we go up to 4x
which is about size 30 32 having that
investment helped us to change and
realign our entire design process we now
have different size bodies to sketch and
drape on in the studio and if more
fashion schools taught these skills more
designers would have the ability to
design for all bodies
[Music]
so as fashion designers is our job to
utilize our platform to explode this
narrow and restrictive definition of
beauty
my goal is that one day teenagers
growing up don't feel the same pressure
that I did to conform and I hope that
our work contributes to the fashion
industry's opening up to celebrate many
different identities thank you
[Applause]
[Music]